hi everyone
this is professor mda science and today
i want to tell you about the ladder and
the number of phrases for the quantum
harmonic oscillator
in another one of our videos on rigorous
quantum mechanics in the context of the
quantum harmonic oscillator
ladder operators allow us to change the
energy eigenvalues by a discrete amount
essentially going up and down a ladder
the reason why lateral raises are so
useful
in quantum harmonic oscillators is that
the energy eigenvalues are
quantized which means that you can only
change the energy in discrete steps
the number operator is a related
operator that allows us to count the
energy quanta
these two operators are used a lot in
quantum mechanics
our plan for today is to explore the
mathematical properties so that you can
use them
easily and confidently from now on in
case you need more convincing
there are also lateral operators in
angular momentum so everything that we
learned today will also help you
beyond the harmonic oscillator so let's
go
the quantum harmonic oscillator is
characterized by a hamiltonian h
whose kinetic energy takes the usual
form
and whose potential energy is quadratic
in the position of eraser
remember that in quantum mechanics the
position and momentum operators obey the
canonical commutation relation
although the two observables that
feature in this hamiltonian are position
and momentum it turns out that to
develop the theory of the quantum
harmonic oscillator there are two linear
combinations of these operators that are
extremely useful
as you may suspect these are the
so-called ladder operators
the first one is a lowering operator and
we label it by a
and it is equal to 1 over square root of
2 then this pre-factor times
x plus this pre-factor times p
the second is the racing operator which
is the at joint of the lowering operator
and it is therefore equal to this
note that we have a minus sign here as
we need the complex conjugate of any
scalar when we calculate the add joint
in principle we would also need the at
joint of the operators x and p
but there are hermitian operators so we
can write them without the dagger
i can probably guess what you're
thinking right now what
is strange linear combination that looks
completely taken out of a hat
at this stage we're just going to accept
that their definition includes
these pre-factors and we will also see
later that this choice leads to a very
convenient expression down the line
we're also for now going to accept that
these operators are called
raising and lowering operators and
collectively called
ladder operators but the rationale for
these names will become
clearer later in this same video
we can invert these equations to find
the position and momentum operators in
terms of the lateral process but i will
leave this as an exercise for you to try
at home
the final result you should find is that
the position operator is equal
to this and the momentum operator equal
to
this the very first thing to note about
the latter operators is that they are
not emission operators and in fact
by the definition they are each other's
adjoint
this means that unlike position and
momentum
the lateral operators are not
observables
at this point you may think well then
why bother if we already have the
quantum harmonic oscillator hamiltonian
in terms of the position and momentum
operators
which are themselves observables what is
the point of introducing
these two new operators that aren't even
observables
as we'll see as we develop the theory of
the quantum harmonic oscillator
even though the latter operators aren't
observables they actually
are extremely useful
let's start with their commutation
relation the only non-trivial commutator
is that between a and a dagger
using the definition of the lowering
operator up here we get this
and using the definition of the raising
operator up here
we get this
we can now expand this commutator into
four terms
the first is between x and x the second
between p and p the third between
x and p and the fourth between p and
x feel free to pause here for a second
to convince yourself
of this step moving on
these two commutators vanish because
they are simply the commutators of an
operator with itself which
trivially commute this here is the
canonical computational relation so we
get i h bar
and this here is the negative of the
canonical computation relation
overall the expression simplifies to
this
this combines to one and so does this
so overall we get one
so in summary the commutator of a and a
dagger
equals one this is a nice and
simple expression and we now see the
motivation behind defining the lateral
process with these prefactors up here
they allow us to have this very compact
commutation relation
we should also mention at this stage
that for the quantum harmonic oscillator
this computational relation between
ladder operators encodes the same
information as the canonical commutation
relation between
position and momentum as you study
quantum mechanics you will find yourself
using this computation relation just as
much as this one
so you will end up remembering both
without a problem
we're now ready to introduce the other
important operator that we will cover
today
the so-called number operator
we label it with a capital n and set it
equal to
a dagger a again
for now we're just going to accept that
this operator has
this form and is called number operator
we will briefly come back to the
rationale behind this
at the end of the video but for the full
description you will have to check the
video on the eigenvalues of the quantum
pharmonicals later
the first thing to note is that the
number operator unlike the lateral
operators
is hermitian to see this let's consider
n dagger plugging in its definition we
get
this the at joint of a product is the
reverse product of the at joints
this here is just a so we get a dagger
a which is indeed the number operator
confirming that it is hermitian
the second thing to do is to calculate
the commutation relations between
the number operator and the lateral
phrases
if we start with the computator of n and
a
we can then plug in the definition of n
at this point let's remember the general
result between the commutator of the
product of two operators a b
and a third operator c which gives
this using
this result we can write out our
commutator into these two terms
this commutator here vanishes and using
the commutation relation between the
ladder operators
we find that this is minus one
so overall we get minus a
repeating the same exercise for the
commutator of n with a dagger
we find that it is equal to a dagger
you don't actually need to remember any
of these combination relations
but we will use them constantly in our
study of the quantum harmonic oscillator
so you should either be ready to derive
them as needed or
you can simply keep a list for reference
okay so we're now ready to understand
why the latter operators
have the name they have to do so
we need to consider the eigenvalue
equation of the number operator
where i label both eigenvalue and
eigenstate
with lambda let's start by constructing
a new state
a acting on the eigenstate lambda the
first result we consider
is that if lambda is an eigenstate of n
then this new state a lambda is also an
eigenstate of n
to see this let's act with n on this new
state
using this commutator up here we just
derived we find
that n a is equal to a n minus a
plugging this into our expression we get
these two terms
as lambda is an eigen state of n we get
this
and overall we get lambda minus one
times
the state a lambda so we see that by
acting within
on this stage we get lambda minus 1
times the same state
this means that a lambda is an
eigenstate of
n with eigenvalue lambda minus 1.
this means that we can rewrite this
state as lambda minus one
and in general we'll have some
normalization constant in front
which i call c minus
so what does a do when acting on an
eigenstate of
n it simply gives us another eigenstate
of n
but the eigenvalue has decreased by one
this is a reason why we call a a
lowering operator
we could repeat the exact same exercise
using a dagger and we would find
that n acting on a dagger lambda is
equal to lambda plus 1
a dagger lambda this means that a dagger
lambda
is an eigen state of n with eigenvalue
lambda plus 1.
this also means that we can write the
action of a dagger on an eigen state of
n
like this and as the eigenvalue
lambda increases by one we call a dagger
a raising operator
this already gives you a flavor as to
the names lowering and raising operators
it will make more sense towards the end
of the video and for the full details
you can check the video on the
eigenvalues of the quantum harmonic
oscillator
to complete the picture let's calculate
the normalization c minus and c
plus associated with the action of the
lateral operators on the eigenstates of
the number operator
if we start with the lowering operator
we first
pick the left-hand side of this equation
and consider the norm squared of a
lambda
by definition this is equal to the bra
times the kit
this here now is the number operator so
we end up with this
using the fact that lambda is an eigen
state of n
we eventually get this this is one
so we end up with lambda we can now use
the right hand side here to repeat the
same calculation
starting with the norm squared of c
minus lambda minus one
it gives this this bracket is one
and we get this this expression must now
be equal to
this expression so we get that the
absolute value squared
of the normalization is equal to lambda
this implies that c minus is equal to
square root of lambda where i have made
a simple face choice so that
c minus is real this means
a acting on lambda gives square root of
lambda
times the state lambda minus 1.
we could repeat the same exercise for
the raising operator
and we would find that a dagger acting
on lambda
gives square root of lambda plus one
multiplying the state
lambda plus one
the final thing i want to do today is to
anticipate
why the ladder and number appraisers are
so useful in the study of the quantum
harmonic oscillator
let's start by writing the number
operator
we want to rewrite it in terms of the
position and momentum operators
so we first plug in a dagger in terms of
x
and p and then a
also in terms of x and p
we can now carry out this multiplication
which gives
these four terms
feel free to pause here for a moment to
cross-check this
these two terms here combine to i over h
bar
times the commutator of x and p which in
turn
gives i over h bar times i h bar which
is equal to minus 1.
therefore we can rewrite the number
operator like
this to make progress we're now going to
build
the quantity h bar omega times n
plus 1 over 2. at this point
this may appear rather arbitrary but
bear with me
and we'll see what happens using this
expression we just derived and inserting
it here
we get this
we can now multiply the h-bar omega
through and
reordering the two terms we get this
and now you can see where we're going
this here is the hamiltonian for the
quantum harmonic oscillator
overall we can write the hamiltonian of
the quantum harmonic oscillator in terms
of the number operator
like this or using the definition of the
number operator
we can also write it in terms of the
lateral parasites
like this as you can see
when we write the hamiltonian in terms
of these operators it takes a
particularly simple form
that will prove extremely convenient we
can now also briefly anticipate the
reason for the name
number operator for n here
as we'll learn in the video on the
eigenvalues of the quantum harmonic
oscillator hamiltonian
energy is quantized this means that
energy can only change in discrete steps
called quanta
and these steps have a magnitude of
h-bar omega
in this context we will see that this
operator
n counts how many energy quanta there
are in the system
hence the name number operator
in a similar way we will find that the
raising and lowering operators are the
operators that allow us to add or remove
energy quanta from the system
hence their name
and we're done here i simply have a list
of the main results we obtained
today we will use them in many of the
other videos on the quantum harmonic
oscillator
so an easy way to keep them handy would
be for you to copy them down
or take a screenshot ladder and
number operators are both extremely
useful when working with the quantum
harmonic
oscillator so it's definitely worth
going through all these maths because
we're going to use these results all the
time as a first example you can check
out our video where we use the lateral
operators to figure out the energy
eigenvalues of the quantum harmonic
oscillator and more generally
ladder operators also play key roles in
other areas of quantum mechanics
including angular momentum or second
quantization and as always if you liked
the video please subscribe